okay well we're glad you've joined us
for this live webinar combining
calcitonin and a highly multiplex
endemic respiratory panel to optimize
antimicrobial stewardship in patients
with lower respiratory tract infections
i am michelle ashton of Weber's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning
brought to you by biomerieux a world
leader in the field of in vitro
diagnostics for more than 55 years
biomerieux is present in 43 countries
and serves more than 160 countries with
the support of a large network of
distributors biomerieux provides
diagnostic solutions systems reagents
software and services which help
determine the source of disease and
contamination to improve patient health
and ensure consumer safety its products
are mainly used for diagnosing
infectious diseases and some critical
illnesses the company's diagnostic
solutions are also used for detecting
microorganisms and agri-food are
methodical and cosmetic products to
learn more visit www.hp.com/recycle
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled ask their questions
and click on the send button questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems being or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problems by type
it into the ask the question box located
on the far left of your screen this is
an educational webinar and this offers
free continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I now
present today's speakers after Devendra
amin medical director of critical care
services medical surgical ICU
neurocritical care ICU at Morton plant
hospital and Clearwater Florida
to learn more about our speakers please
click on the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr. and game unit may now begin your
presentation I good afternoon everybody
thank you for joining us it's an
interesting topic with a lot of changes
over my lifetime in medicine which makes
things I think somewhat easier to manage
these patients with respiratory tract
infection the objectives of the talker
to review and assess the burden of asura
tract infection upper and lower review
the efficacy of highly multiplexed
respiratory panel in this scenario and
also to review the data on antibiotic
stewardship with procalcitonin as you'll
see combining procalcitonin with the
highly multiplex retort panel has a
great opportunity helps optimize
antibiotic exposure in patients with
respiratory tract infection
don't begin with a case the clinical
case kind of case that we see every day
in recently in my experience a tussle 76
year old female comes in with short of
breath cough chest pain multi productive
cough breathing yellow sputum she denied
any fevers but her symptoms appear to be
worse at night he also has a large room
edema and had a fall from unsteadiness
about two days ago without any practice
she was a several oxygen saturations 97%
on room air and occasional basal
crackles enough location
the white count was twelve thousand
eighty percent polymorphs BNP was
elevated 1390 d-damn was also elevated
at 9:40 and the PCT was less than 0.05
at about 4:00 p.m. when she first
presented chest x-ray code
infiltrates with x-ray on the left hand
side is the one from the current
admission and the one on the right hand
side with some a previous admission
about three weeks ago three weeks prior
it was ready showing some basil
infiltrate possibly improved compared to
the previous study the very ambiguous
picture a bunch of things in the
differential diagnosis that could this
be heart failure could this be a receipt
or a tract infection viral bacterial and
also the patient had an elevated edema
could there be a PE as to the cause of
the patient shortness of breath and
symptoms
at this point [ __ ] know what the
audience thinks about starting
antibiotics based on the current
information you'll see the question onto
there
and an option to respond
by the next morning russia tory viral
panel came back which was negative and
the PCT was also in the normal range of
0.06 so based on this information in the
clinical history if one had started
antibiotics would anybody stop them or
continue antibiotics so the question is
would you stop any value at this time
assuming they were started and we review
the answers later
you
so looking at a cute wrist retract
infection it's a very high burden in
children and adults the third most
common cause of death worldwide breast
Victoria viruses accounted probably 50
to 60 percent of retro correct
infections rapid identifications and
potential to reduce antibiotic exposure
the initial appropriate antivirals and
to initiate appropriate antiviral
therapy we'll need it for influenza and
then it may precipitate earlier
discharge or discharge removes you into
home if there's a viral etiology as
opposed to a bacterial infection
pneumonia but probably possibly beyond
the bronchitis
so the fact hostel admission also like
to stay and can also impact on hospital
infection control measures if you know
the kind of organism you're dealing with
which some cases need isolation in many
cases need isolation some cases that
don't need isolation
respiratory tract infections and non
influenza viral infections are the most
common illness in humans 70 percent of
surveyed patient has at least one
episode in the previous year averaging
about two and a half episodes a year
with very common viruses mouth branches
like run of our enterovirus producing
with some 500 episodes internationally
in the u.s. meeting duration of the
illness about 7.4 days they can be quite
debilitating and don't forget people are
quite infectious in the first half of
that usually and 20 million lost work
days and 31 billion loss school days as
a result of this there's an increased
burden and severity of illness in
patients with coexisting diseases such
as asthma COPD and otitis media but an
annual bill approximately forty billion
dollars
this is a study from the New England
Journal 2015 looking at community-wide
pneumonia patient that actually had an
infiltrate and they look to see if
there's any specific pathogens so of the
3,600 or patients about 24 ata were
eligible to go into the study with
adequate data 21% required ice you can
2% died 300 2259 patient has x-ray
changes suggested of pneumonia and this
included bacterial and viral specimens
pathogens are detected in 853 patients
are only 38 percent of patients about
60% of time we didn't or they didn't
identify the actual etiology of the
illness as you can see from the table
there viruses for about 23% of these
infections bacterial infections rather
than by Levinson's of time only 3% at a
time with a coexisting viral and
bacterial low percentage of fungal Mecca
bacterial and amongst those viruses 9%
with Rhino virus six percent influenza
strep pneumoniae at 5% and unknown 62 as
we said
this is the breakdown graphically they
didn't really break out atypical
pneumonia that's going to be other than
mycoplasma their Legionella
but there are others as you'll see that
also can contribute especially comedic
in some studies as many as ten percent
can be chlamydia
you
does this and
when you have a 60% of the page we don't
know what's going on at the front end
leads to potential for overuse of
antibiotics which results in a safety
risk to patients developing
developmental antibiotic resistance and
other comorbidities such as the death
and this also increases the rate of
death in patients who have unnecessary
antibiotics as well it's estimated two
million doses from 23,000 with the best
result from inappropriate antibiotic use
cultures can take some time to get
results back to three days and they have
virtually no sensitivity a faster more
accurate indicator of infection is
needed to help in these critical
decisions in milder patients maybe not
so critical but in particular patients
is quite important to know as much as
you can at the front end to help with
appropriate therapy and triaging
this is that about 50% of my device
described for acute respiratory
infection is probably unnecessary from
this study is about sixty eight point
nine million patients about thirty four
point three million were felt to get
antibiotics unnecessarily
so when using appropriately antibodies
carry the risks as mentioned with more
serious illness or disability higher
death rates for long recovery and more
frequent hospitalizations and the use of
unnecessary or clogged use of
antibiotics and then this is very common
in the two syndromes especially lower
respiratory tract infection and in
sepsis
so there's some tests that we use
commonly already for detecting what kind
of infection money you might have and we
commonly use strep pneumoniae antigen
and the Legionella Nyonya urinary
antigen they can come back fairly
quickly they help with triaging they
help with antibiotic selection or
de-escalation fairly quickly we've been
using influenza enzyme immune absorb and
SSDI a zuv pcr but they've been very
slow they can take a few days to come
back and with costly m RSA is something
that we've been using for some time now
as a nasal swab to help predict whether
and ammonia is related to a Marseille or
not it has a highly predictive negative
value so that if a patient is negative
4m r sa you can deescalate from adding
on vancomycin in the setting of a
healthcare-associated pneumonia and
we'll get rid of that potentially toxic
medication if the mRNA is negative the
PC on people follow that rule fairly
well on the home
in this very high negative predictive
value the multiplex panels allow the
detection of multitude of viruses and a
few bacteria and they're now able to get
results back within an hour or two
depending on the lab and the logistics
of getting a specimen from the patient
to the lab and back to the EMR
for this study by Brenda's out published
in the lancet looked at the use of rapid
Diagnostics and antibiotic stewardship
in less advanced infection the
hypothesis of that if you have this
point of care fairly quick turnaround
test you would hopefully reduce
antibiotic initiation or at least
duration and maybe decrease length of
stay
but despite having rapid identification
of respiratory viruses that was founded
in the in the actual results that the
number of antibiotics initiated was
really no significant difference in the
tube with the point-of-care testing
versus not the first groups got about
eighty four percent of the time had
antibiotics however there was a
reduction in the duration of antibiotics
in these patients and in the patient of
the point-of-care testing there was a
significant reduction in duration one to
two days of antibiotics so that did help
like a test for influenza and
restricting Sileo virus and other
respiratory viruses systemic business
systemic review looking at the accurate
diagnostic accuracy and clinical impact
is a retrospective review of a bunch of
studies as we'll go through the
algorithm some of the some of the
testing was just an influence of someone
influenza plus RSV and there was the
primary multiplex title in this and they
use the methodology using the Cochrane
Database for diagnostic accuracy testing
so start it off with some 4,100 studies
but after screening learning eligibility
and looking at the criteria for
Diagnostics within each study they came
down to about 56 studies a diagnostic
testing accuracy and 15 studies for
impact of the algorithm or the
hypothesis
so that the accuracy of the new attest
is actually very good the cool
sensitivity in about 91% the pool
specificity was about 96 percent if
you're only testing for influenza been a
very high sensitivity specificity when
you added RSV to that in the simplex ER
and others the accuracy was pretty good
for the sensitivity of 99% when you get
into the multiplex I say there's a
slight reduction in the overall
sensitivity but that's what the entire
panel if you look at the specific
influenza A B and RSV there's a 97 to 99
percent acitivity and specificity so
much more accurate these tests also
could be more accurate in children
because their viral loads appear to be
higher and the more variance there are
they the better the sensitivity and the
diagnostic accuracy of the test
and in this study but the turnaround
time was average was less than three
hours but this did result in the reduced
length of stay and also more appropriate
use of Tamiflu oseltamivir for patients
diagnosed with influenza A or B so there
was some value
in the impact size of the study tour
with the risk for a viral panel and PCT
with guidelines that is a combination of
RB PMTCT viral pathogen detection may
not necessarily tribute causation was
one of the thoughts coming out of the
study because just because something's
there doesn't always mean it may be the
causative agent for the illness so that
was part of the thought process in the
study doesn't happen too often but as
possible and the rapid molecular tests
with viral pathogen detection provided
accurate results the clinical impact of
rapid diagnostic tests were conflicting
there is high-quality evidence that
rapid testing might decrease the length
of hospital stay and might increase
appropriate use of so common influenza
virus infection they suggested
considering implementation of rapid
molecular tests within hospital settings
and recommends performance of high
quality randomized studies and I think
the key to this was to actually get
education on the ground you can
implement the search you can put it in
but if you don't educate the people
sending the test and interpreting them
for a clinical impact to a high degrees
and the test is useless you have to have
good at good education on the ground to
allow people to determine that you have
a test that has a high positive or high
negative value and then follow the
results and you get better results so
the trend in that direction but it's
been slow as you've seen with other
testing
study pediatric study comparing six
sample to answer influenza A and B and
restaurant rates and super virus and the
multiplex studies from respiratory
specimens some children over a period of
years in the Clint respective examples
that were available compared to the
fda-approved assay which was a reverse
transcriptase assay for a and B and RSV
sample to answer platforms based on
nucleic acid amplification detection of
these viruses were simple automated and
accurate the high sensitivity and
specificity we've seen at a rapid
turnaround time which is the key to
adoption if you get the result back in
the first day or first half day of the
admission or within the ER time you get
a much higher application of the
algorithm and people actually paying
attention to the results and maybe
avoiding antibiotics if you get results
that quickly otherwise the tendency is
to start antibiotics and then continue
them for maybe two or three days longer
than you might ordinarily do if you yet
have you results that quickly there was
overall a decrease in antibiotic use and
appropriate use of antivirals in this
study as well
this is looking at the the breakdown
with flu again a very high percentage
sensitivity and specificity to see
across almost all the tests that
influenza B again slightly lower sensory
specificity compared to influenza A
that's common amongst most tests for
this except for the ones that are just
measuring a and B and then for RSV again
a pretty good sensitivity specificity
there all across the board
the bio fire respiratory panel menu
provides a whole bunch of other viruses
as well 17 in total initially I felt and
I think many people because you know
these are not so serious in common but
they don't need significant treatment so
why no well if they're hospitalized and
you don't know but you know they're not
influenza A or write over or RSV all of
these patients you can see from the CDC
guidelines they do require some form of
isolation if a patient's of the URI a
viral respiratory tract infection who
you think is a bacterial and they're
getting antibiotics but all the time
they're shedding virus and they don't
have appropriate airborne precautions or
contact precautions or droplet
precautions are necessary then you're
spreading the infection even though it
may be mild the other thing about the
panel is that you also get Bordetella
chlamydia mycoplasma and which require
droplet protection so that's kind of
important as well micro plasma pneumonia
as you know we treat all four of those
with this relaxed or sort of quinolone
preferably with a litter mattress and so
it's important to know that and once you
have that you can deescalate antibiotics
so that's a very important part of the
panel we feel that does help with
antibiotic de-escalation or narrowing
down what you're on
for the impact of a rapid russet or
panel test on patient outcomes
indentation in the study of the biofilm
are a risk to a panel to improve
outcomes and the pediatric study before
and after implementation this is in
children better than three months of
acute respiratory tract infection they
had batch PCR influenza A and B RSV and
parainfluenza and post him post testing
when they had the new tests available
which was a and B RSC parent blends and
want to cool human metapneumovirus
adenovirus advisor of arsenic rotavirus
so that was the new test and it was over
two winter seasons
similarly when you look at this study in
the pre multiplex study number of
patients 216 there was no influenza A or
B and that was because from the paper
they said that the previous year they
had a very bad flu season and everybody
got vaccinated a lot of children about
vaccine it gets not everybody my
rotations in this study but actually
they did not have this lens maybe they
had the other viruses and some of them
would not perform vision how to test
available in the following year post our
Pisa with the new assay and they did see
influenza and they were able to pick up
these other viruses including the
metahuman right so much 10% of the
patients as I gather not so serious
respiratory viruses
and these were outcomes related to
timing of the test with the previous
test the average time to test result was
about four hundred ninety minutes this
is the new test about two hundred ninety
minutes or two significant difference
PCR results received in the emergency
room 13% in the pre RP and in the post
RFP it was almost 50 percent to patience
of the test within the EOS a significant
change
antibiotics unfortunately was still
prescribed that is similar in about
seventy percent but antibiotic use and
duration was decreased a little bit and
then the inpatient length of stay was
also reduced but not significant the
emergency room length day was reduced in
time and time to isolation was again not
significantly different
there's AlterNet say there was a
positive results of rfp impacting
outcome it's provided for early
discontinuation antibiotics a slight
decrease in length of stay and reduce
time in isolation
because the impact from this study rapo
study impact on the early detection of
respiratory viruses by multiplex PCR on
clinical outcomes in adult patients and
they compared to winter season 2010-11
and 2011-12 and infections of that goes
by conventional assays in the first
season and by the multiplex fire fire
assay in the second season the film
arrayed decreased the time to
Diagnostics diagnosed and influenza
compared to conventional by one point
seven hours to one point seven hours
from seven point seven hours that's
significant and the film array also
decreased the time to diagnosis of non
influenza viruses 1.5 hours or six
thirteen point five without significant
with multiple
mystic regression showed that diagnosis
of influenza by the by accounts
associated with significant reduction in
admission length of stay duration
antimicrobial use and number of chest
radiographs as well the rapid turnaround
was key
having the result early and the
multiplex nature the tested like the
Civil pay inspection of viruses and
superior sensitivity to memory may
improve the evaluation measure a patient
suspected having respiratory viral
infection
so that's come a long way from what I
started training in terms of what we
could do we did weren't able to identify
viruses that easily or if we did it took
several days is very expensive this has
really changed the paradigms it allows
you to send patients home very quickly
if you have that diagnosis with a mild
viral infection or two influenza to get
housewives to get the time accrue fairly
quickly assuming again they're waiting
too long on the outside and get them
appropriately triage and treated the
next part of the talk is looking at
procalcitonin a lot of us dissimilar
views and procaster and acknowledging
sepsis but in the respiratory tract
infection world I think has a very good
role especially in the setting of viral
infection with this negative predictive
value as we'll see
not one thing
and close it there we go
so it's been on the market since about
2007 it's true privity creative uses in
the USA to aid in the risk for sepsis
and septic shock in the first day of
admission I determine the change in PCG
level of a time probably I see admission
which has a prognostic value to it
she's a precursor of calcitonin the
health regulate the inflammatory
response bacterial infection this is
normally produced by many tissues only
parathyroid however converts ECT to
calcitonin normal serum concentration
about 0.05 monographs the more or less
bacterial infection stimulates PCT
production in multiple organs where the
PCT is not broken down as it is in the
thyroid gland and same concentration go
as high as for Grandin 22.5 a
significant prevents an infection or
greater than 0.25 and then can reach as
high as 40 to 100 and we have erratic up
to 200 and we can see that they can go
higher than that even with a very
serious inflammatory response to
infection
good biomarker information is produced
by numerous organs as we said PCT arises
is about three to six hours of the
bacterial insult a systemic major insult
the half-size about 20 to 24 hours it
allows the early identification and risk
assessment and elevated levels the high
positions of a severe bacterial
infection this has to be a systemic
infection to cause the elevation
as you can see from this cartoon model
here if you have a viral infection it
stimulates interferon gamma which
actually does not stimulate the homo
kind
calcitonin mRNA and does not produce an
elevation in procalcitonin if however
you have a bacterial infection you have
a simulation of interleukin 1 b1 beta
and TNF alpha which stimulates the
calcitonin mRNA which causes the Golgi
apparatus to produce a lot more
procalcitonin 3 procalcitonin that gets
sent out into the serum and does not get
cleaned by the enzymes which you would
normally find in the peritoneum and
Penzer levels are very high so viral
infections do not elevate procalcitonin
levels as actual infections do so that's
one way of differentiating between a
very slow and negative procalcitonin
elevation setting of a sick patient with
bilateral infiltrate which are not
always summer bacterial infections
bladder infections can preach the same
level of information along then you have
good grounds to believe that this is not
that gel this is viral also helping
triage your antibiotics as we'll see
this is the time line that you see with
these various inflammatory markers and
within the first hour or two interleukin
6 10 until about fairly quickly and come
down PCG takes about a couple of hours
to start rising continues to rise and
then as you take away the insult the
levels come down fairly predictably if
there's normal renal function
let's see next slide
p CT kinetics as you can see the levels
right surely quickly opened up and the
total infusion and that continued to
rise an ongoing insult however the level
drops down with a half-life of twenty
four hours as you take away the insult
predictably by fifty percent per day
DCD levels significantly a higher
impatience bacterial co-infection
comparative viral infection only on the
left-hand side you see a violin section
only and you see a bacterial infection
increasing the PCT when they have both
infections if it's a serious enough
bacterial infection
these levels also carry with disease
severity the seen we have sirs steps
just today such as a septic shock the
levels go up quite significantly as you
can see and linearly
disease I've also have a high negative
predictive value lowest recurrent
infection there in the setting of a
bacterial infection the deposits
addictive value and a negative picture
value if the levels are low the level is
it's a very high probability a negative
value with a low C c/g levels in the
scope study as you see that the
sensitivity is 84 percent specificity
98% positive addictive value when the PC
is high is 90% the negative additive
value where the PC is low is nice 4%
PC is a critical biomarker for Bachelet
infection and aids in assessing risk of
the specificities affected infection
versus inflammation alone rises rapidly
off the bacterial insult declines
rapidly with control of the section and
there's an excellent correlation with
severity of illness
so in the lower risk you attract insects
captions are often not specific and
patient resent as we said from the very
first study that we showed case study
that we looked at call experience
emissions of breath and attorney
nonspecifically borrowers in ammonia is
it heart failure
all of those can occur with those
conditions and respiratory tract
infections can present in many different
ways and with it the cube bronchitis
pneumonia or the kid exacerbation of
COPD will having very similar
presentations and side effects
improve
but the physical characteristics as
we've seen with cough speed material a
very nonspecific and then this ambiguity
almost everybody got antibiotics they've
given the tools that we have now with
the viral markers and with a bacterial
marker and I think it's more predictive
now in how it's able to treat patients
more accurately
so divide us from CCGs a was the first
athlete to be created to aiding
decision-making on antibiotic therapy
for patients with suspected or confirmed
lower races or tract infection defined
as comedic ride ammonia to bronchitis
acute exacerbations of chronic
obstructive communities and then in
patients in an inpatient setting or an
emergency department setting
so the algorithm that recommended to
follow is that the PCT value on the on
initial presentation less than point one
probably you don't need antibiotics in
the setting of a respiratory tract
infection strongly discouraged if the
PCT is point one to point two five again
one would discourage
the use of antibiotics if the patient is
clinically stable if on the other hand
given the clinical situation and the TCT
is elevated 0.26 2.51 will encourage
antibiotics and certainly greater than
0.5 in the setting of a clinical picture
of pneumonia let's say one would
strongly encourage antibiotics
the de-escalation on kinetics allow for
you to have a fairly rigorous
methodology for discontinuing a d-bag
because the PCT drops down to less than
0.25 or has dropped by more than 80%
there's good data in showing the
patient's the pneumonia bronchitis
accessor bation ta PD with the bacteria
if they have a battery infection then
one can discontinue the idea by exactly
at that point again reducing the
significant duration antibiotics from
several days ten days down to less than
four or five days
a study published in the lancet looking
at records of London idea records from
the literature search of which 71
articles were accessibility after
exclusion - 19 records
collected data on six thousand seven and
eight patients from 26 agile trials in
12 countries so they looked at the
patient level data which are able to get
from each of the study prints
investigators and they looked at
mortality at 30 days which is
significant lower and procalcitonin
guided patients and in control patients
5% tests and a 336 3036 per customer
guided patients versus 336 or 10% in 300
3372 controls would adjusted odds ratio
point eight three for the companies into
a point seven two point nine nine the
mortality benefit was similar across
subgroups by setting attachment section
with a p-value greater point zero five
for the mortality was very low in
primary care and in patients of acute
bronchitis as one would expect
procalcitonin guidance was also
associated with a two point four day
reduction antibiotic exposure ranging
from five point seven verses eight point
one and reduction antibiotic related
side-effects sixteen percent versus
twenty two percent that's very
significant
the use of procaster joining the
diabetic treatment inpatient acute
respiratory infections reduces
antibiotic exposure and side-effects and
includes survival
why should implementation of
procalcitonin protocols and phases with
two particular infection sub has a
potential to improve antibiotic
management the positive effects on
clinical outcomes and on the current
threat of increasing antibiotics
multi-drug resistance
if you look at the outlines of the
mutual analysis looking at baseline
characteristics the respiratory tract
infection we looked at the effectiveness
for initiation antibiotics effectiveness
and antibiotic duration exposure and
effectiveness and safety profile
based on characteristics similar between
groups in liti patient level meter
analysis in terms of distribution of sex
communica ammonia acute bronchitis or
cuticle activations of COPD PCT value
initiation was 0.23 this is point two
one
and then when you look at the
effectiveness or initiation of
antibiotics
see on the left-hand side of the panel
there's propensity to face a PC with
lower PTT is significant for antibiotic
initiation so if you didn't start
antibiotics based on the fact that he
chose less than 0.25 there were no
adverse outcomes based on that as we
move forward you'll see that and then if
you have
on the control patients which is on the
right-hand side of that central line
very few that one just above one little
bit beyond the right line
I definitely reduce antibiotic
initiation
four percent versus eighty eight point
four percent
you look at the effectiveness antibiotic
duration of exposure
we're seeing is again is this liver
reduction in Eurasian exposure from the
three randomized control trials patient
level at the patient level seven and
then for ten in the controls and days
and as a patient level the total
antibiotic exposure days five versus
nine
reduction in genetics closure in
inpatient and emergency room setting for
LRT I as you can see from the two panels
there as is that a 38 percent reduction
anybody exposure from days of enrollment
and then even more so in the emergency
room
pneumonia fewer patients with cap in PT
group and antibiotics through follow-up
and then you can see a 37% reduction
that you've got exposure in terms of
duration
bronchitis a very significant 65%
reduction antibiotic exposure that a lot
of patients would started or if they
were started with it was reduced earlier
to a patient of the gate accessories of
COPD and CCG group on antibiotics
throughout follow-up
a 49% reduction in total exposure
look at the safety of doing this it's
all very well something or reducing and
doing surgery but did it cause any harm
by doing that you can see there was no
significant difference in the outcomes
or the odds ratio was very similar in
both in terms of risk
you
and here we see similar rates of
mortality there's no difference in
mortality if you follow the PCT
algorithm to reduce antibiotics so you
gain by reducing antibiotic exposure you
gain by less side effects and you gain
by not adding it an increase in
mortality rate
and there's also a significant reduction
in incidence of complications which
included death I see admission
hospitalization realization acute risk
for infection specific complications and
recurrent or worsening infection
hustle length of stay was similar in
boats and the kids exacerbation of COPD
is a slight reduction compared to the
control groups
and then the 30-day mortality rate this
is a different difference
the piece all right
Oh
you
the PC can be safely and effectively
used for two additional mutations which
was brought up by the FDA in February
2017 the agent decision-making and
antibiotic therapy for patience is
suspected of confirmed mr. tract
infection defined as comedic red
pneumonia icky bronchitis and kids
exacerbation of COPD and 280
decision-making and relatives
continuation based on that nature
analysis so helps in decision-making on
studying patients and also on
discontinuing patients from antibiotic
utilization
so this your indication is important and
may help reduce the unnecessary use of
antibiotics which is a serious issue
especially if former comes with
resistance to ever c.difficile
and then there's an herbal safety risk
good unnecessary antibiotic exposure as
you can see
the p55 map is to help guide effective
treatment decisions it's been already
studied in cases of such an LTI and
sepsis and associated with decreased
athletic use without worsening clinical
outcomes
the rapid detection using PCT can help
with this as was the case with the viral
pcr as well for the multiplex panel
again all these any test you use has to
be used in clinical context as you apply
them perfectly in clinical context it's
really strengthens your hand in
antibiotic utilization
Mazda marching PCT levels gives you data
to make better and more informed
decisions
additional Gunther initiation
continuation antibiotic therapy is
improved prescribing practices to slow
the rise of resistant bacteria and it's
supposed to CMS guidelines of antibiotic
stewardship and section Prevention
now
how the viral panel can work we've seen
how PCT can work so how do we optimize
antibiotic stewardship in the setting
where you have both available which many
places do now
so with that combination we should be
doing much better with antibiotic
utilization and reduce use of
unnecessary acrobatic
so this study looked at utilizing the
respiratory panel virus to our panel and
PCT to help introduction of antibiotic
exposure and the results were as well as
proven or possible Brigitte or
infections as indicated by monsta x
testing respiratory bacterial cultural
international statistical classification
disease and related health problems
using the Revised Code for cures for a
tract infection these are documented the
patient's requires how to RP which a
great panel or PCC within the first
template as a presentation
drug voters are evaluated with
discontinuation of antibiotic therapy
they coded out the programs and this is
going to find a positive viral
respiratory panel result or both so
within 72 hours the presentation if
you've got the data you should be able
to discontinue antibiotics if the viral
panel is positive and the PCT was
negative or low
what they saw was that with the low PCT
the the two groups with the PCT SS 1.25
in the positive viral Connell showed
that the ICU admission rate was similar
in both groups was very higher in the
low PTT group than in positive viral
power boots the median length of stayed
was high in the PCT group the positive
viral panel was lower so how the
antibiotics prescribed when much higher
in the low PCT group than expected at
71% when the positive viral respiratory
panel was 28% much lower but if you had
the PCT less than point two five and a
viral panel that was positive the I
admission rate was higher than makes
sense that in the median quota median
length of stay was in between the viral
and the PCT being low group and the
antibiotics prescribed was individually
higher than the viral panel alone so
even with a low PCT so it looked like
the data was there but people weren't
really paying attention do that as you
can see the anybody prescribing per se
two hours was about 70% even with a load
P to do point to five significant lower
if you just had a viral sted study by
itself but even with a low PCT and viral
panel being positive six or seven
patients got antibiotics
a piece of geography
in 503 and 1823 patients respectively
results of these tests suggested 789
patients with potential candidates for
antibiotic avoidance he's in pain 219
with a low PCT and 601 with a positive
viral paddle and 31 with both
antibiotics who administered have the
Salem patients than 10 percent of the
patients in the first 72 hours but they
were discontinued within 48 hours of
laboratories data availability
diseases are suggested positive viral
pounds and reputation results are
infrequently assertive disconnecting
light therapy improvement of possible
respiratory infections that have their
institution direct intervention the
clinicians are likely to correct the
theater and decrease unnecessary and
erratic you so unders how much education
actually went into educating the staff
or robust antibiotic stewardship program
it plays to help direct antibiotic
therapy given positive and negative PCG
clearly education with key doing any
tests but not paying attention to the
results doesn't add value but if you
actually pay attention to the results
and you believe in the data that's
available then it will produce results
as in a significant reduction in
exposure
other study from a similar time frame
300 patients hospitalized with non
demonic lipi October 2013 to April 2014
when I resigned and a one to one ratio
to substandard care for PC regarding
care and highly multiplex PCR testing
primary outcome was anybody explosion
safety was assessed at one in three
months
so you could see in the Greenline
non-intervention group the median
exposure was higher than in the yellow
line lo PCT and virus positive so in
this study people were paying attention
the significant reduction in antibiotic
exposure as you will see
fifty-one patients in the intervention
group viruses were then but according to
percents and 83 percent had PC values of
less than 0.25 again there was no
significant difference in X but acusó
adverse events between intervention
patients as a non event group at the
beginning that subgroup analysis
revealed fewer subjects with positive
results of viral testing and Olympic
values who would discharge receiving
antibiotics so less people would send
home on antibiotics if they had a
positive viral and negative PCT value
trota antibody generations among
algorithm and hearing intervention
patients versus non intervention
patients to versus four-day so that was
significant reduction and device
configuration then with historical
control from 2011 but at six days
average
so the antibiotic use is similar to on
subgroup analysis of intervention
patients suggest a physician responded
to position responded to viral and
biomarker data and this hope is more
fruitful as we go forward
there brings you to the next case the
last case 69 year old male with coughs
congestion short of breath
low-grade fever for about ten days crisp
you damn wife and grandchild had been
sick with similar symptoms
medical history of the hypertension
coronary disease can just about say a
diabetes sleep apnea Tmax is 99.5
occasional basal Krakow's auscultation
hypoxic 90 percent on room air why count
was low PCT was low at point two that's
at 5:00 a.m. on the day of admission and
the chest x-ray again showed bilateral
ffs disease it was quite significant and
again the first question is given the
information you had there I think most
people give me this question would you
son handi-vac should probably say yes
more data patient was started over 7-zip
to match the community quite pneumonia
see how that came back positiv by 9:00
a.m. the following morning and positive
human metapneumovirus and the PCG maker
0.15 so this is the non bacterial
infection and of course the obvious
question is would you stop antibiotics
on day 2
we did and the patient did fine but
that's with a lot of experience in this
studying
so overall summary rapid diagnostic
results are important negative
predictive value below PCT command with
a strong positive predictive value of
highly multiplexed procedure panel has
potentially reducing antibiotics
projects significantly
the real-time interventions improves
results so getting the sample to answer
should be
Espie a sample to answer with real-time
intervention approves results and then
reduces link to stay and also in reduce
antibiotic cost and enzymatic associated
complications
at the end of the presentation I think
we'll be ready for questions shortly
thank you for your attention
Thank You dr. Amin for your presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of the presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button dr. Amin will answer as many
questions as time permits all right our
first question is what is the turnaround
time for PCP and the respiratory panel
I'm sorry for the time turn around
yes what is the turnaround time yeah in
our hostel we can usually get a PCT back
if it's a stat PCT we can usually get it
back within an hour
realistically sometimes a little less
but to go from the patient to lab and
back again on the M about an hour
respiratory viral panel it all depends
on you know how the order gets picked up
and then gets taken but once the sample
is taken we can usually get it back in
an hour or so
great thank you okay next question how
reliable is procalcitonin when taken
within the first 24 to 48 hours of
presentation but after antibiotics have
been initiated
that's a very good question usually the
patients if they're very sick bad
pneumonia it can take a couple of days
for the PC to turn around and start
dropping down but if it's a let's say a
not so bad by a bacterial infection it
can start dropping down within 24 hours
or so so as you saw the half-life is
about 20 to 24 hours so given an
appropriate antibiotic for a couple of
days prior to getting the first PCT you
may be back in the normal range or just
above the normal range so you may miss
the peak that's right it's very
important to the emergency room to get
the first sample in the emergency room
as then you have your baseline because
oftentimes it'll go up before it comes
down and turns around so it is important
to get that very first sample as early
as possible and you may get a false
negative if you have already had a
couple days of active and it's just like
blood cultures if you've already had
blood cultures you already had a couple
days antibiotics as an outpatient with
an oral antibiotic and you do plug
countryman serum they may be negative
because of the fact that we have some
antibiotics on board
but yeah good question
great thank you okay next question was
your pharmacy team involved in creating
protocols for PCB testing and antibiotic
usage
well we do have or have had an
antibiotic stewardship program where
pharmacists have reached out and called
physicians saying that you've got a
negative PCT you're on these antibiotics
and you have a positive viral and for
the most part they'll get a good
response and discontinuation of
antibiotics you got to make sure of
course there's nothing else going on
like a UTI or something else where they
mainly an antibiotic but they do the due
diligence for that and it's been very
successful but it can be positioned
dependent on whether they they actually
follow the algorithm or not so it's more
education as needed clearly everywhere
great thank you we have so many great
questions coming in okay let's see your
next question is let's see you have
recommended educating the clinical team
but what is the best platform for this
webinars or in services Grand Rounds or
what grabs the collisions attention to
act on these tests
I think a combination of say Grand
Rounds or little group meetings within
departments to showing the data they can
see show data that helps that we had
this number of bacterial infections this
number of violent sections proven by the
viral panel and negative TCG let's say
and we continued antibiotics for this
number of days is there any way we can
improve on this so I think education is
key and I think Grand Rounds are
important and also I think within
department meetings looking at data
because physicians by nature can be
competitive and given a challenge the
appropriate challenge that can rise to
that so and it's important to show data
your local data as to how this happened
because you know study performed in a
teaching hospital somewhere showing X
result doesn't often translate to what's
happening in the community but then
sometimes we find that some of the
studies coming out of teaching hospitals
a published but show that they didn't
follow protocol and that's why they were
negative
so you know education is the key
great thank you okay next question it is
unlikely to have virus and bacterial
infection at the same time if the virus
is positive would adding PCT not be
cost-effective do you suggest
both respiratory rdt and PCP together
for all patients are only four selected
PTF it seems not cost-effective to
perform both tests in all patients
yeah I think if you have a clinical
syndrome now both of this case studies I
showed when non-bacterial and there was
enough in the history to suggest that
they were viral in the second case the
family members were sick which doesn't
happen with a Bachelor infection so you
had a good idea that this was going to
be a non bacterial infection so RB PLN
would have been fine
and the RVP there was positive beginning
of a new virus and you know there's no
treatment for that specifically just
symptomatic treatment in the first case
there's a combination of CHF trauma
causing the elevated D diabetic
CG Angela negative for PE and both the
studies were negative I think when it's
very straightforward one test or the
other is fine but I find that from my
experience where I'm working in the
hospitals that I work at a single PCT
often isn't enough for a physician see
I'm not going to do this we might get a
second PCT on the second day and that
really confirms that the negative
predictive value is very high with two
PCTs and then you might not need the
viral except for the benefits of doing
the viral is that you now know if it is
positive that you have a virus that
requires isolation may not require
hospitalization because if you don't
isolate that patient with say RSV then
they're going to spread it and then FX
your staff that affects other patients
so it is helpful having this information
um you know
you
great thank you
just a reminder for our audience you can
still submit questions at this point
while receiving so many any questions we
do not get to we will make sure to
follow up out for the web part over
that's all we have time for today and I
want to run
there was one of the question I saw here
about the low incidence it says though
instance that one study showed a low
incidence of combined bacterial and
viral but I think it's we've seen a
higher incidence of both especially in
the flu season and patients will get
post viral bacterial infections as well
so I think they can benefit in the
sicker patients to know exactly what
you're dealing with
oh sorry no that's okay thank you all
right well I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions so any questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand laberd's will alert you
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye